if June is the month of III then may is
the month of III leaks and rumors for
PlayStation Plus subscribers it's also
another month with some free games for
you to grab if you want to know what's
being offered this time around I've got
you covered
first up on ps4 is beyond 2 souls this
adventure game comes from developer
Quantic Dream and director David cage
which means it's full of those big
choices that can totally change the
outcome of each scene in this case those
scenes involve Jodie and the disembodied
soul Aiden that possesses her if you
want a more active adventure on ps4
you can also platform your way through
Rayman legends you can jump through each
stage with up to 4 players in co-op and
with over 120 levels to be that's a lot
of quality time you can spend playing
together on the ps3 side things get much
more destructive with eat them this
arcade game puts you in the shoes of a
giant monster letting you destroy a city
and snack on its citizens for more power
and yes you can enjoy the destruction
with up to 4 players here as well if
you'd rather go on an adventure by
yourself ps3 is also getting risen 3
Titan Lords
this action RPG tasks you with fighting
back the shadows in a land where the
gods have abandoned everyone quests all
across the world can end differently
depending on your choices as for the
Vita you can solve physics-based puzzles
with Furman's you want to guide the
fluffy little critters to the bucket at
the end of each stage and to do that
you'll need to place special items to
guide them along the path good thing
there's more than one way to solve each
level and that's not the only physics
based puzzle game the Vita is getting
your goal in King oddball is destruction
and you accomplish this by swinging
around a giant boulder attached to your
tongue flinging diamonds at targets
thanks to cross buy you can also give it
a try on ps3 or ps4 and those are your
free PS plus games from a they'll be
available from Tuesday May 1st until
June 4th remember that you can always
check out gameplay clips and reviews for
these titles over on GameSpot and if you
want to keep up with all of our top
stories you can grab the official game
spot now app on iOS and Android
[Music]
you
[Music]